un de mes préférés mais très vite c'est
un arabe je fréquente beaucoup dans sa
noble qui parle avec dieu et il lui dit
dieu s'il te plaît j'aimerais j'aimerais
vivre jusqu'à 90 ans et tu lui dis tu
avais jusqu'à 90 ans mais qui lui dit
oui il dit est ce que tu bois il dit non
je vois pas est-ce que tu fumes et non
je fume pas il ya ce que tu as le vis
des femmes
sinon j'ai pas le vis des femmes il ya
pourquoi tuer jusqu'à 90 ans maintenant
alors
[Applaudissements]
un petit garçon ces intégrations il va
pêcher tous ses copains touzet et chaque
fois qu'ils rentrent chez les copains
ils voient ou au mur un galaxy fit avec
jésus et il voit plus syfy il rit et
puis tout d'un coup ils regardent le
copain il fait 10 dont signalement
heureusement que jésus-christ ils n'ont
pas noyer tu fais pas scotché j y aura
un aquarium c'est un couple d'aristo
essai c'est marie chantal et
charles-henri sont en train de prendre
le thé dans une magnifique demeure et
tout d'un coup marie-chantal lui cher
charles henry qui est ce que ça vous
plairait de faire l'amour à trois et en
salle henri les wii devient tout rouge
comme ça et tu mets mais évidemment ma
dulcinée
oui oui oui oui alors effet allés à la
une la deux
[Applaudissements]
et
il faut la faire passer cela dans le
même genre le mec est dans une boîte
toit où il ya un peu des défis bill est
un peu seul qui l'a moi tu avais un
petit peu fermé tu vois
oui mais ne femme j'ai par contre je
n'en sais rien filo jablah jeu et il ya
une vieille frangine qui arrivent et qui
lui dit écoute je suppute de toute
fraîcheur je fais franchement tu viens
avec moi tu vas te régaler si ces gens
j'en ai replié de la peau de serpent
j'en ai déroulé du câble tu peux me
faire peur et j'habite juste à côté et
ses 200 euros et bondouy 4h45 du matin
infiniment et part avec l'arrivée chez
elle est là chez elle lui dit baye à
17h07 dirait la mère et la fille a avec
lui alors là c'est un autre week end là
tu me relance complètement la soirée
bien sûr que samedi et la lafa me dit
maman tu peux
[Applaudissements]